هذه هي الصهاريج التي تضم مخزونات نفط
كردستان الخام بعد توقفه لنحو اسبوع بسبب
قرارات المحكمه الفرنسيه ومن هنا ايضا
سيستانف اقليم كردستان تصديره للنفط بعد
اتفاقه المبرم مع بغداد ولاول مره
البيانات الصحفيه لحكومه اقليم كردستان
العراق اكدت ان رئيس الحكومه مسرور
بارزاني بتوقيعه الاتفاق مع الحكومه
الاتحاديه سيرسي اساسا نحو عهد جديد من
التعاون الثنائي المستمر بين اربيل وبغداد
بحسب
[موسيقى]
البيانك بالتاكيد هذه الاتفاقيه تصب في
مصلحه الشعب العراقي وهنا اود ان اشكركم
وان اهنئ شعب كردستان والشعب العراقي
واؤكد بان هذا الاتفاق سيكون اساسا مهما
للموازنه وحتى لقانون النفط والغاز ان تم
تنفيذه بشكل مضبوط بالتاكيد ان ايقاف
تصدير نفط كردستان كان مضرا للاقتصاد
العراقي ولم يكن مضرا لشعبي كردستان فقط
هذا الاتفاق جاء حصيله حوار ونقاش استمر
لايام
بروح مهنيه
وبرغبه صادقه لايجاد حل مشكله الكل متضرر
منها وتقبل الاتفاقيه بان شركه التسويق
سوما الوطنيه هي من ستقوم بالاشراف على
بيع نفط اقليم كردستان بالاسعار ذاتها
التي تبيعها بغداد ما يشكل فارقا كبيرا
بالاسعار كون اقليم كردستان كان يبيعنا
باسعار اقل من السوق العالميه هذا فضلا عن
ان نائبه مدير شركه التسويق سومو سيكون من
حصه الكرد بحسب الاتفاق هناك تفاؤل وهناك
طابور خامس يريد ان يزيل هذا التفاؤل في
داخل شعب كردستان ولكن الحقيقه واضحه لن
تحجبها اشعه الشمس وضياء الشمس لن تحشي
بها الغربال مرحله جديده من الثقه
المتبادله في التعاطي مع جميع الملفات
العالقه ما بين اربيل وبغداد جسدتها
مباحثات وصفت بالشفافه لتنهي حقبه عقد من
السجالات ما بين الجانبين احمد الحمداني
العربيه
اربيل